and by the way I wasn't going to comment
on sharks for a little bit I don't like
all the positive press
sharks have been getting as they
continually eat people
indiscriminately for no reason
and they're constantly like this
submarines videos who's always like oh
sharks are being killed all the time
it's like
okay but what did they make the soup
Chinese people make the soup shark fin
soup
is that my is that my problem the
Chinese people kill sharks and make soup
and I've never had the soup if the
soup's good I'm hey but this idea that
sharks are like docile loving creatures
has to be smashed same with pit bulls
pit bulls are vicious Killers they're
monsters and I'm not saying
but they attack babies all the time
like there was this show Pit Bulls and
Parolees where they like teamed up pit
bulls with violent people and I'm like
how does this help like the pr campaign
or the image of a pit bull how about a
show called like pit bulls and people
who've never been convicted of a crime
but they were putting violent people
together with violent and I'm like
pitbulls are violent dogs they Maul
children all the time it's how they're
raised not really always no it's
intrinsic to them they're bred to be
murderers and many people get upset when
I speak the truth I'm not saying don't
have them but know what it is
sharks also are are are not good
on the whole and I don't mean there's
individual sharks that are decent but as
a whole thing they're bad and I love
swimming in the ocean and people like
well the Sharks do the home of the ocean
it's like is it like there's a lot of
people well there's a lot of things in
the ocean
and they go well the Sharks the oceans
home it's not your home it's like well I
don't want it to be my home I just don't
want to get eaten in the thing idiot I'm
not like colonizing the I'm not like
putting I'm not like calling the Four
Seasons like make ocean hotels and [__]
with them I'm like don't eat me and
every time a shark like rips someone's
arm off
like everybody defends the shark like
when that shark ate the guy in Egypt and
they were clubbing him the Arabs thank
God for Arabs sometimes not always but a
lot
sometimes you know because it's not
great with this ass in the face of the
women all the time and throwing the gays
off the roof I certainly don't like that
um and that's why Beverly Hills Hotel
people said why do you go there uh
because they're from the country where
they throw the gays off the roof and I'm
like if I have to have lunch the Waldorf
I'll throw myself off the roof because
it's not good the John George or Beverly
Hills is not good the point I'm saying
now is that the Arabs were clubbing the
shark in its head because it just killed
some Russian guy who I think he was
Russian right
well whatever he's in [__] the water
and this tiger shark's just playing with
his body killing him
and then the Arabs find the shark I
don't know how someone did make a good
point did they just like beat a like a
just a shark
did they just find like a shark that was
in the water and grab that shark to just
get Vengeance on a shark but even that's
kind of understandable if it was a war
between sharks and humans which is a
little but I'm hoping it was a shark
that ate the guy I don't want them to
bludgeon an innocent trunk but In the
Heat of battle my point is I think it
was the shark that ate the guy and
they're clubbing the shark on the boat
trying to kill the shark and like doing
the taunts you know our probably good
Arab you know taunts to him
and they killed him and and then I said
it's it's the world's not about right
and wrong it's about power the shark had
it in the water because everybody always
rushes to defend the shot like all these
tough guys on Twitter think it's cool to
defend sharks eating people get that up
get that up with the legs like that
look at this you want to see the video
no let's not play the video because it's
like old news but like just make that
bigger with the legs
so the shark ate this guy
and all these people are defending him
he's like well he was in the water he
should be eaten and I'm like well okay
how about I mean the sharks can eat
the other things in the water like the
seals
right
that's my I'm just not always like let's
defend the shark
all these people on Twitter are like
well that's the shark's home and
okay but I'm just saying like we should
be the boss of them we're smarter than
they are they don't have what we have we
should be better like we we own the
animals we are the boss of all the
animals on the Earth
it says that in the Bible you have
dominion over the honor no we are the
boss
they're not the boss the animals are not
the boss
we kill them all the time and go we're
putting up condos and we will continue
to we're not they're not the boy the
animals are not the boss I don't care
how big and bad they are oh I'm a big
bad shark kill it poison it poison the
war we poison the war kill all of them
we'll kill everything on this planet
we're the boss
no so it's true now when the shark kills
this guy everyone's like well he's got
the right two and Andy God thank God for
Egyptian people I really because they're
clubbing it to death which is a show of
power
now
what is that they're hitting with a club
right a medical yeah a metal pole we'll
get to kill someone now
this ocean Ramsay freak I've had enough
of her I want you to go to her Instagram
and by the way don't start this
harassment campaign but I'm saying with
this was she swimming with the sharks
all the time
and she's going this shark so and the
shark almost go to news because the
shark almost got her the other day she's
hot so people tolerate this Behavior she
almost dives into a shark's mouth in
viral video watch this show must start
and I'm not hating on her I'm just
saying like
I'm getting a little tired of like this
like dick riding of sharks like I
understand you know what I mean like
here she goes she's diving
yeah he's trying to eat her and she's
like oh it's fine he's hanging out with
us
we're just friends me and this shark
this is like the lunatics who lived with
bears and then the bear eats them
remember that documentary The Grizzly
Man yep she's gonna get eaten One Day by
one of these sharks and she's gonna be
like I why is why are they doing this
because they're your enemy like birds
birds are natural enemies if Humanity
hate human beings
they hate them Birds attack people I was
a tour guide on a tour bus birds with
[__] on it they hate Humanity they used
to be dinosaurs they're now Birds it's
all facts and they hate people
and it's true and I hate them
but I like looking at them and they're
very pretty and Majestic but what it
comes down to it they it's your conflict
they go into plane engine it's like they
have to be regulated you have to
regulate sharks they have to be
regulated